the head coach in the New Orleans Saints
Sean Payton how are you Sean I'm doing
well rich I didn't know if it was me or
butt-dialed me but no it's good to be
honest I know no it was me it was me
it's definitely me how you doing what is
life like that post draft I figured
let's let's let's go underneath the Sean
Payton hood here what's going on with
you right now yeah so we pushed our
offseason program back by a week yeah
we've done that before when we've gone
into Plateau sir
got a little deep into the fluff so our
players are in the building now and just
lifting and running you know we don't we
don't spend a lot of time in meetings or
whatnot you know that they're coming to
the facility really just getting their
bodies in shape you know most of them a
lot of them have you know been training
already and and then meanwhile we'll as
coaches preparing for the upcoming
rookie can't wear you know the draft
picks we'll be in for that camp the sign
free agents after the dress will be in
and then we're also allowed to bring in
guys on a three day tryout and so we
just met on the rookie camp that we're
having next weekend they'll be probably
around 65 players here the third of
which will be draft draft players yeah
free agents and I would say two-thirds
will be on a trial basis well it looks
like you got yourself a new center well
with the first overall pick of your
draft in the second round out of Texas
A&M that kid Eric McCoy it was a really
nice moment for us in our draft coverage
to look in on him when he was apparently
there on the phone with you or Mickey
Loomis finding out that his dream was
coming true he's not only going the NFL
but he's gonna snap the football the
Drew Brees of all people what was that
like when you got on the phone with him
Sean well I listened it it was one of
those situations that you just part of
the great thing about our job you know
the difficult thing is when you're
sitting down in your office and you're
involved in you know releasing a player
but conversely on the other end of the
spectrum oh it's that day when you're
making a call and it was fabulous I mean
the excitement in his voice you could
hear it in his family's not that wasn't
able to see
the TV version until later but but no
we're thrilled to have him you know
joining our club and it was just it was
a good moment to see now how did max
obviously max hungers retirement
reconfigured your draft board and this
this is an obvious need for you I mean
is that we can easily draw a line
between the two that this kid's gonna
you're gonna throw him out there week
one when you're out there we're gonna
see this kid play for you yeah look a
fair question and yet I would say one of
the things you try to do in free agency
is not put yourself in that position we
sign Nicky stand from Minnesota the
plate sort of for them a full season
it's Center and and also play guard for
them so you know we we feel like with
the addition of Nick and then also the
opportunity to select Eric all of a
sudden you know it it goes back to a
position of strength and a lot of it'll
depend on how we see the inside of that
line shaping up relative to those two
players and then obviously the
flexibility and quite honestly we think
Eric can be a swing guard as well now
what do you do on the first night of a
draft you don't have a first round draft
choice walk me through what that was
like in Europe well all every every
element that that you typically do
during the weeks leading up to the draft
take place the same way the board set
all of us the grades are set oh you're
all in there you got your you know your
sport coat or suit on it's the person
first round because you don't know if
all of a sudden there's that opportunity
with a team to to move forward and if
when I would say fairly you know one
remarkably I mean I went fairly smooth
there were maybe a few trades maybe a
couple surprised picks and it ends at 32
and here you go and more importantly
when it ends you've got you know a
couple hours to look closely at it
knowing you're gonna get started the
next day 6 p.m. an hour earlier but
really a chance to to begin to target
maybe a few player
make some notes relative to who you
think fell it maybe you were surprised
that so aside from that pretty much the
same so do you have any thoughts on on
our surprise pic that that fell you want
to throw one out there Sean well look it
no no there's no way that everyone's
boards are gonna read the same and so
picture the column set underneath throw
walking in the column underneath throw
to in other words graves equivalent to
what we feel like is the second round
pick not only this year but last year
five years from from now and looking
forward I mean what's the standard for
that player and so periodically in the
first round a picks made in you look up
and you move over to the second or third
round maybe where you had a great not as
high on a player in the good part about
when that happens that you just know it
incrementally kicks a player towards you
so without you know hitting a certain
team or two teams or three teams but
that that's pretty common to take place
and in really three years from now you
know that the team's selecting and all
of us you know get to find out more
specifically hey would you do it again
that's the question we always ask what
would they do it again and I and you're
I don't think there were maybe just two
players that were uniquely maybe
selected before we thought they might be
the quarterbacks are always tough to
predict because that's a position that
rightfully so is valued very high and
you're also evaluating the draft
coverage at the same time right Sean
will try Mary with with with Eisen and
network and secondary with the ESPN on
note how should that and you know if
we're ever selective and you guys on
commercial we switch over but you guys
do a great job and you know I don't
think people realize how difficult the
coverage of that event might be in
relative to the names just the amount of
on-air time you guys do a fantastic job
Thank You coach and I agree with that
evaluation
I absolutely agree I second that
evaluation in the limited time we owe
your on I mean that's a marathon it is I
mean it's tough to sit on one's ass for
as long as I did over the last three
days and in Tennessee tell me about the
zebra technologies and how you use the
information that comes from it
Sean well our legs using it now and it's
what it's what our what our fans are
getting when we hear next-gen stats or
we here Alvin Camaro runs 22 miles an
hour on a given play or where the
personnel are on the field and it's it's
just simply the scan technology that's
in a grocery store zebra really through
their code pattern anytime you're
swiping out some grocery product whether
it's ketchup yeah it could be concert
tickets airline tickets there's always
that barcode that's that's zebra so
they've kind of partnered with the
league now for the last three and a half
four years certainly with us as the
Saints but they're able to give you
they're able to give you in game and
also in practice distance traveled
exertion all these things that we would
want to track that we're all doing now
so what used to be you know you kind of
say hey that was a tough practice we can
actually you know evaluate what is a
tough practice and it might be tough for
one player and not as tough for the
other so it's helping us with injury
prevention and I think it's also moving
into not a skiing but but the evaluation
of other teams relative to where they
play players in what positions that
they're playing or where their splits
are located so it's all you know in game
scanning and coding that's awesome do we
have two minutes left before our heart
out at the end of the hour ask the poll
question of Sean Payton I'm curious to
see what he has to say to their answered
or coach which event in May are you
looking forward to the most Kentucky
Derby PGA Championship NBA Conference
Finals NHL Conference Finals the Game of
Thrones finale or the Indy 500 all right
so right away I'm going to narrow the
list down Thrones is going to be up
there Derby is going to be up there and
the PGA Championship coverage is going
to be up there so we've eliminated NHL
NBA more specifically than
go eat you gotta fill with the the Derby
here for me it would be Derby one
Thrones - fantastic before still alive
after Thrones they all right so I've got
a minute left here Shaun if I give you
the first overall draft choices - who
wins Game of Thrones who sits on the
Iron Throne
you have the first overall selection you
choose who how are we not choosing the
gal that just killed Dark Knight I mean
how we not picking her Arya Stark right
she's she's the first overall selection
well she's certainly trending and her
great just went up I'm taking her
tremendous upside tremendous upside I
agree and my backup pick is the
three-eyed crow I think those two just
have special powers no one else that
coach thanks for the call really
appreciated you the best salutely you
bet that's Sean Payton for more of the
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 on DirecTV for free on BR Live or
download the Rich Eisen show app